as max freed makes his home debut
tonight 17-game winner last year one
ball two strikes from free
and strike three of the big breaking
ball and diaz can't believe it max off
to a good start one out
and a swing and a miss at a fastball
two strikeouts for max free to start his
night
now the o2
a swing and a miss how about some
left-handed compliments for max freed
and for ryan yarbrough work quickly and
utilize your defense
this one lifted into right
renfro's going to go back he's on the
track with roone a couple steps before
he made contact with the wall
waiting to get it down
to the left side and this is
making the play
and in the center that's margot on the
run to make the catch and retire the
side atlanta's got two on nobody out and
that's it sets the table very nicely for
dansby swanson has gotten off to a red
hot start
line drive right field base hit ozuna on
his way to third he's gonna round the
bag they're gonna bring him home
he's gonna be late he got in with a head
first slide
aggressive sin by ron washington
renfrow charged the ball made a good
throw
but ozuna had the back door open and he
slides home ahead of the tag and dansby
does it again it's one to nothing young
man's off to a very good start with
runners in scoring position
that's lifted toward right renfro long
run near the line and he's going to make
the play
tagging at third and scoring is duvall
riley puts it in play sac fly he'll get
a big hand from his teammates and the
braves have scored their second run
lined and caught by camargo
marco robbed of a hit terrific play by
johan who reached up and speared that
two outs
2-2 pitch
did he go yes he did that's 11 up 11
down for freed who struck out five the
first time max has faced the tampa bay
rays i'm pretty sure they're not liking
what they're saying so much
ground ball to third camargo's got it
throw to first 12 up 12 down max freed
is perfect through four
this has been a strange year all around
and obviously going to be a much
different season
so
tap genino with the grab and the quick
throw down to first to retire swanson
up the middle and that's going to go
through beneath the glove
alby's with a backhanded attempt shaded
that way and the ray's got a base runner
oh freed perfect through four and
two-thirds
now you got to get joey wendell
in a two-nothing game wendell's been
their hottest and best hitter
and they just picked him off first wow
he may have given up a hit but russo is
gone
he couldn't check his swing and cenino
strikes out that's seven for free two
outs
and a cut and a miss and a big strikeout
of freeman
down to third
and a stop by albie's and
he has decided to just step on the bag
to retire the side
down the hill he comes with a 3-2 pitch
breaking ball yanked along third fare
ball down the left-field line all the
way up against the sidewall riley goes
over to chase it adamus around first he
pulls into second a terrific at bat by
willie adams has turned into a two-out
double
max freed brilliant
rosso's going to be lifted in favor of
choi
because after the first pitch had a base
head into right
adamus on his way to the plate he's
going to score
and just like that the rays are only a
run down
joy swinging at that first pitch coming
off the bench
so the rays have been able to cut the
lead to one they're down two to one and
it's been really thanks to ryan
yarbrough he has been that good
from the line and pitches back door
breaking ball called strike three one
out in the seventh ryan yarbrough with
the
air
high fives knuckles glove
[Music]
sharply hit a nice stop there by diaz
throw to first in time and the stretch
by choi
good on the other end i'll tell you what
how about the feel of yandy diaz number
one you've got to range to your left and
then realize there's no way that i can
scramble to my feet and still throw out
albies so i'm gonna glove it and i'm
gonna throw it from a knee
swing and a fly ball to left that's
pretty well hit duval on the run he's
got it a sliding catch at the base of
the wall
what an incredible play
took over for riley and he sprinted all
the way to the warning track lunging
catch went to the ground and held on
what a great catch by adam duvall
meyer leads
twitching
going
pitch ball throw to second is a strike
and he never slid
kier meyer never slid unbelievably and
he's thrown out
swing and a miss and that's your ball
game the braves have beaten the rays 2-1